Adding ribbed bands with the machine can be a challenge.
If you prefer ribbed bands,
take it step-by-step and you'll
be happy with the results.
The key to this is that knitting
with the ribber, we must have
even weight on the stitches.
We do this with a ribber cast on comb.
This is the trickiest part of this method.
Start by establishing how many
needles you'll need for your band.
Keep in mind that ribbing pulls in,
so plan ahead accordingly.
On the main bed, cast on with waste yarn,
cast on over every other needle and hang
the ribber cast on comb in the loops.
Knit a few rows of waste yarn
and then knit a row of ravel cord.
With the wrong side facing.
Hang the edge of your
cardigan on the needles.
After hanging the stitches,
it's good practice to close the latches.
Using the main bed carriage, knit one row.
The ribber is not in work yet.
Next, raise your ribber and attach
the ribber connecting arm.
Transfer stitches down to the ribber
in the needle arrangement of your choice.
I chose to knit 2x2 ribbing.
Thread up the ribber carriage and knit
the number of rows needed for your band.
Then transfer the ribber stitches up
to the main bed and loosely bind off.
Use the bind off method of your choice.
When the band is complete,
remove the cast on comb and the waste yarn.
And you have a beautiful
ribbed band on the machine.
When you're knitting on a standard gauge
machine like this, you might find that
a single layer of ribbing is too thin.
So knit twice the number of rows.
Fold the band in half for a doubled band
and secure that bind off edge with a whip
stitch to the front edge of the sweater.
A single band may work
for a bulk or midgauge yarn.
You need to test to see
what you like best.